alright ladies we are here at I heard
what brings you out here and who you
excited to see
well we just got like swamped by
Fleetwood Mac yeah that was we gotta
like pushed into a wall for them like if
flute Arab is pushing you into wall are
you planning that I just like take it I
had it was it was almost like we hung
out with them yeah yeah I mean my toe
but Ruby next birthweight oh so did you
finish Gambino really great excited to
see Sam Smith but I just heard he's sick
but it's great for us because now we get
to it what do you call it introduced
panic at the disco with Darren Criss
useless like getting why I was gonna say
I was gonna consent no I was gonna pay
for that but I bet network it's not
we're doing I keep saying I'm presenting
at iHeartRadio Festa that I guess that's
not in Chrome's my Fleetwood Mac there's
a lot happening already and we've been
here for like 20 minutes I gotta ask you
guys I just think you're so funny on
social media like I loved when you
posted was it on Catherine's Instagram
like I should have been invited on this
beautiful trip and she was like mommy
and daddy need time how was the
hilarious she plays into my jokes very
very well and it makes me really happy
because I'm always saying crazy loose
are you guys I mean how happy are you
for your dad because he seems so happy
we have a great dad and I think any kid
why me not we're not kids but you know
any kid wants to see their parent yeah
and it seems like she really makes him
happy I mean they were saying like this
had kind of been this long relationship
and now we've really realized this
connection we have is it kind of crazy
to see that come to light
yeah I don't know it's just we're just
have
ya know ya know it's where it's perfect
you guys bridesmaids is their wedding
date we have not had no one talked to us
about it when he joked though that we'd
make me like flower girls ring they're
here as she said mommy and daddy needed
the traffic well stop to ask you guys
Kate Hudson's about to pop and I asked
Jen Meyer this what do you get a woman
like Kate Hudson as a baby gift like
she's just so amazing and has like did
you guys have any ideas what what do you
get her but she really loves presents
yeah you throw her a baby shower she
loves to gift but she loves a gift
she'll take it's like she actually likes
like handmade things she's seen it so
she'll knit you something so if you
don't get to be homemade it's kind of
like she's like the most beautiful
pregnant person and her and Goldie Hawn
like Goldie said something about how it
was gonna be like a Magnolia blooming
I'm just like Ellen DeGeneres that was
amazing really cute
they have the relationship that we all
want with our daughters she seems so
happy like she's found this great guy
she's having a girl finally like are you
guys super happy for her I mean well you
just had your dream come true with
Fleetwood Mac but what do you guys have
coming up next what's next for you -
we're doing a lot of things that he
can't like say but we've got a lot of
the pipe and we'll be good yep right now
we're really focused on bumble we're the
creative directors at bumble and it's
been so exciting watching launching
bumble biz bumble bee FS connecting
women all over the world we're very very
focused and passion about that right now
and we have a television show to network
it's all good
you